[Music]
this is hyperloop you might have heard
of it it's a mode of transport that
combines near vacuum tubes with
magnetically levitating trains to create
almost frictionless ultra high speed
travel
or it would be if it existed
see while the idea has been around for
centuries a 2013 white paper by elon
musk sparked a slew of student
competitions and startups all trying to
turn hyperloop into a reality now
there's way too many players for me to
name all of them but you might recognize
names like virgin hyperloop hyperloop tt
and the boring company these companies
have received millions of dollars in
investments they've designed mock-ups
some have built test tracks and one has
even carried passengers
yes
so with the technology being mentioned
in both president biden's infrastructure
bill and eu sustainability studies does
that mean that hyperloops are about to
become a reality well maybe one day but
right now it's not quite there yet
[Music]
so as always we're going to look at
where the companies are right now where
they want to be and then examine what
they need to do to get there but let's
start with where these companies want to
be
their aim is to use the hyperloop which
they say can travel at speeds of over
700 miles an hour to connect distant
cities in record time at affordable
prices
hyperloop tt founded in california in
2013 say that their technology could
slash the travel time from chicago to
cleveland to around 32 minutes twice as
fast as flying and virgin hyperloop
backed by virgin founder richard branson
say they could connect chicago to
columbus in 45 minutes compared to a
six-hour drive and it's not just the us
companies like netherlands based heart
who in 2021 received around 17.4 million
dollars in funding from the european
union planned to deploy their technology
across the globe from europe to the
middle east now while none of these
companies say exactly how much tickets
would cost many say their aim is to make
tickets accessible and affordable but
that's all in the future and right now
those routes and ticket prices are all
hypothetical
for now these companies are still trying
to prove that their technology can
actually work to do that they've struck
up partnerships with engineering
heavyweights the likes of airbus tata
and hitachi they've secured funding some
in the tens of millions others in the
hundreds of millions of dollars from
state and private investors many have
worked with their local governments to
help shape standards and regulations and
some have signed provisional agreements
with companies cities and countries to
further develop the technology and some
have developed initial test tracks
hyperloop tt has constructed a 320 meter
test track in toulouse in the south of
france and virgin hyperloop have also
developed a test track a 500 meter run
in nevada which has actually carried
test passengers hart have also worked
with the dutch province to begin
construction of the european hyperloop
centre a collaborative testing ground
and while the boring company has dug a
series of tunnels around las vegas and
california so far the only thing that's
carried passengers down them is a fleet
of teslas though the company did tweet
that hyperloop testing would begin later
this year and it looks like they're
hiring hyperloop engineers i tried to
speak to the boring company but they
didn't respond to my requests for
comment so if some of these companies
have been working with government some
regulation received funding and
constructed test tracks why aren't we
quite there yet well this technology is
still unproven at scale and as such
there's some safety concerns like how to
evacuate passengers from a near vacuum
tube or how to avoid a collision between
two carriages traveling in short
intervals if the lead carriage develops
a fault there's also concerns that
earthquakes and temperature fluctuations
could cause sections of hyperloop tubes
to misalign over long distances and that
could lead to accidents even if those
issues are addressed some experts also
worry that rapid acceleration in a
windowless chamber could make passengers
feel sick now when i've spoken to these
companies they've told me that they're
working on solutions for these problems
hyperloop tt for example say that they
have worked with partners to develop
safety isolation valves that would
isolate portions of the track in an
emergency
and when i spoke to spanish hyperloop
firm zeleros they told me they were
exploring using different materials and
different pressures to make the system
safer over long distances
even if those safety concerns are
addressed there's still the matter of
getting agreement and funding for what
would essentially be a huge years-long
infrastructure development project and
it's that that's left hyperloop in a bit
of a chicken and egg situation see these
companies say that the best way to prove
that their technology works and is safe
is to build it at scale but doing that
would take time and money and as this
tech is unproven right now some
companies told me there was a reluctance
to invest however these companies may
have a way to demonstrate that some of
their concepts can work without having
to move passengers by moving cargo
instead pretty much all of these
companies have plans to deploy their
technology at ports in the coming years
that could give them the first chance to
demonstrate whether or not this will
actually work though it might not answer
all of those passenger safety questions
so what's it going to take to turn
hyperloop from a computer rendering into
your future commute well first these
companies are going to have to prove
that their technology can economically
move cargo once they've done that
they're going to have to demonstrate
that it can be safe for passengers after
that they're going to need backing from
cities and governments to deploy their
huge infrastructure projects at scale
finally there's just a small matter of
securing the millions needed to build
even a single mile of hyperloop and then
convince passengers to hop aboard if all
that happens then maybe just maybe one
day you might be able to travel across
america in record time without ever
leaving the ground
[Music]